I wonder if I shouldn't study and
not study today.
I would like to talk about why it is better not to study English
If you have listened to my video
, please subscribe Please register
Click on the bread to receive
notifications Why did you stop studying English?  I thought it would be better if
I studied Chinese before I studied Nechi Japanese.
That's what I remember, so Nyan-chan means doing something you don't want to do even if you put it down
.
That's
because when you look at the actual brain building, you
don't know what you don't like or don't like, but it
's extremely regrettable that you want to learn it.
I have to stop studying
and do something fun.I'm going to have a little talk
today.I made a website with the word link for her.
I study from Nana-sama,
that study, study, study, and study again, but if it's a great
method, I listen to it and choose it
.  And
if there's a library like that in the link, if you don't have the contents of that lesson vacation, you can introduce it
into something popular from anywhere and use it.
It's all kinds of death penalty, for example, children,
then dad, that's mom,
you read stories for your kids,
but if the voice sounds like
that,
if dad thinks mom is boring,
if she doesn't like to talk,
babies can feel it too.  That's why, and that's
what it is, it's a new word
It won't be developed. It's an actual experiment.
Rather than that, in order for the child to discover the words, it's better for the father or mother to actively read the
stories that they find interesting
.
That baby is a small baby to Izu Because he doesn't understand anything yet Because
he's in a position to absorb only the sound and the word itself
It seems that it's more effective to read aloud for the sake of
the teacher
.
If you don't have one, it's very effective.
If you want to study in that same class,
another thing is that if the teacher does, Google will teach you.
You make your own rules It's
fun and interesting if you have
that input If you ask me where it is
I
don't have a lead impression my
brain is thin Don't
memorize each word
There are so many different things to grasp,
one by one
, when a word comes up in a sentence, you forget it, or there is a connection that comes up again.
Tamada You make your own rules
.  I
always remember I always make rules
So you have to give enough stimulation
But that stimulation is interesting for the brain
.
Reveur doesn't have to teach you that much,
for example, it's a story about babies again, but then there's Shilk's answer
, isn't there?
It
's
very complicated to figure out how to apply that strength to your own muscles.I can't do it at first, but
little by little, little by little, the happenings of the garden one by one
won't remain in my memory.
In
general, if you follow some rules and move in this way, you can walk, and your head
will make wool.
You don't have to tell Alf that it's a shoe box, but you can
teach him and follow it.
Babies make their own rules
.
Well, first of all, start by speaking in your native language.
And if you get a lot of stimulation in a foreign language,
you'll still have some brains, rolo.
A baby's brain tries hard to create a rule, but in
the case of English, for example, there are various
types of fillings,
but that work
is a senti.
-Pink Tomorrow
So the rules aren't necessarily accurate, and little by little little by little
there are changes, and the
more and more correct patterns come out
Of course, you can read the rules of that grammar
Choose  But if you already have enough experiences
like that, you can look at the rules to the extent that you can see the rules that you thought this way
or that you didn't think so.  Your brain automatically
learns various rules, and from among them, you
should come up with the correct way to express yourself.
The hypothetical pattern of the people who are laughing at that is because it was fun to listen to, or because it was fun, it was very
useful for
pronouncing
it.  No matter what it is, everyone in Korea and China has a boring voice,
that narrator who can't sit down is
doing it right now, right?
I don't want to say 3 Enchant anymore, so let's stop studying and have fun
learning.
I think that words probably appear in my conversations like that,
so at that time, each and every one of you studied English.  Even if it's useful, that's
why
my current youtube charm is also my favorite billion English video.
Please listen to it.
Well, you can look at it in such a way, you can
introduce it to the link, and r is around the tower of the wing
.  Hello Cyber Hmmm 12min 1min [musi
]